Salut, nous sommes en pleine semaine spéciale micro-expressions
Alors certains d'entre vous sont déjà en train d'écrire dans les commentaires
que ce tee-shirt a une faute d'orthographe
Ce n'est pas une faute d'orthographe, c'est une référence à un ancien fait divers
Je vous laisse rechercher un petit peu, si jamais vous ne connaissez pas ce fait divers
C'est en rapport avec Omar m'as tuer
N'oubliez pas que dans la description de cette vidéo il y a une playlist
qui regroupe toutes les vidéos sur les micro-expressions de cette semaine
et la première que j'avais faite sur ce sujet il y a également un lien
*Inspire profondément*
Faut que je respire de temps en temps
vers le livre de Paul Ekman qui est la base de tout le travail actuel sur les micro-expressions
Et aujourd'hui on parle de la 5ème micro-expressions à savoir
La Peur
Je vous parlerai également d'un site internet pour s’entraîner
Générique
Avoir peur ou être un petit peu angoissé c'est une émotion très courante
Nous sommes souvent soumis au stress et l'approche d'un danger déclenche cette micro-expression
Alors les dangers, tels qu'on l'entend basiquement
mais également d'autres qui sont moins évident
ça peut être la réponse a une question qu'on nous a posé
et à laquelle on se sent contraint de répondre
des choses qui nous gênent
Les muscles rentrant en jeu sont:
Les muscles orbiculaires c'est à dire les paupières supérieures qui se soulèvent
La pupille qui se rétracte
La bouche qui s'ouvre légèrement et qui peut tirer vers la droite ou vers la gauche
dans les généralités c'est pas forcément un muscle du visage mais on se raidit,
On se met en position d'attaque donc on contracte nos muscles
et enfin les sourcils qui se lèvent et qui se rapprochent
vers le bas, je vous rappelle c'est la colère et le dégoût
et enfin tout ces signes sont accompagnés d'une action
qui est le fait d'inspirer
on inspire durant la micro-expression de peur
parce que le corps va chercher de l'oxygène
En fait, il se raidit, il va chercher de l'oxygène
la meilleure défense étant l'attaque
Le corps se prépare aussi à attaquer
F. Hollande: J'ai donc confier, à Manuel Valls, [au ralenti] J'ai donc confier, à Manuel Valls,  Valls
D'où se déclenchement d’adrénaline quand on a peur
il y a pleins de situations où le fait de détecter une émotion de peur chez quelqu'un
Vous permettra de comprendre ce qu'il ressent vraiment
C'est un peu la micro-expression négligeait des mentalistes
et pourtant de mon point de vue elle est vraiment essentielle
donc je vous recommande de la bosser
Ouais, ouais ça c'est bien la bosser ouais mais comment on bosse les micro-expressions mon petit bonhomme
Vous êtes nombreux depuis 2 jours à me demander comment on pouvait travailler ça en ligne si possible
Alors j'ai creusé, j'ai essayé pleins de sites internet depuis 2 jours
Il y en a beaucoup, la plupart d'entre eux sont payant malheureusement
Il y a aussi des formations en ligne qui sont ultra chères aussi
Je vous rappelle, quand même, que ces vidéos là que je vous fait elles sont gratuites
à la limite vous pouvez payer d'un petit like et ça coûte pas bien cher non plus
Vous, vous pouvez vous entraîner rien qu'en regardant la télé
Plutôt des émissions, des talk show, des débats ou des choses comme ça
Mais j'ai quand même trouvé un site qui s'appelle 'Émotions ninja'. Je vous mettrai le lien dans la descritpion
il est plutôt bien fait
C'est payant mais
il y a un entrainement sur 10 photos qui est gratuit au départ
donc vous pouvez vous le faire plusieurs fois
Il y a aussi, évidemment, les excellents logiciels qui sont disponibles sur le site de Paul Ekman
Je vous mettrai aussi le lien dans la description
C'est payant, c'est pas donné
néanmoins ce sont les meilleurs que je connaisse
Il y a jusqu'au 15 novembre 2016, j'ai vu sur le site
sur la page que je vous mettrai,
il y a un code de réduction
euh... je crois que c'était 20% de réduction
c'est jusqu'au 15 novembre 2016
Il y a pleins de possibilités, moi je vous recommande juste de prendre le face plus combo
si vraiment vous voulez acheter quelques choses prenez juste le face plus combo
c'est largement suffisant
ça donne déjà de très solide base
Au cours de cette semaine je vous ai proposé quand vous conversez avec quelqu'un de vous concentrer sur des points
clés du visage
et de les regarder un peu du coin de l'oeil
Et quand ils bougeront pendant un quart de seconde
vous serez plus attentif et vous allez pouvoir détecter facilement les micro-expressions
parce qu'avant d'analyser il faut savoir détecter et c'est aussi le but de cette série
Alors pour continuer en rajoutant la peur à tout notre package
qu'on se fait progressivement depuis lundi
Prenez conscience que le visage de l'autre en permanence
gardez à l'esprit de regarder les yeux,
l'écarquillement et à partir d'aujourd'hui la rétractation de la pupille
les paupières supérieures et les petites rides autour des yeux
pour le regard rieur, pour la joie
les lèvres, les sourcils en entier, le nez ici et ici, le menton
et les joues
et ça y est, on est vraiment sur le visage en entier
Merci beaucoup d'avoir regardé cette nouvelle vidéo du Mental Vlog
petits Mentalos que vous êtes
Ils ne nous restent plus que 2 micro-expressions à voir
A savoir le mépris et la tristesse
J'ai vu également dans les commentaires que vous me demandez les émotions de séductions, les émotions....
du bonheur, ce genre de choses
Ce ne sont pas des micro-expressions
Cette semaine on voit les 7 micro-expressions majeures
ce que vous me demandez ce ne sont pas des micro-expressions
donc d'abord on va terminer les micro-expressions
N'oubliez pas, également, de vous abonner à la chaîne du Mental Vlog
C'est une vidéo par jour depuis le 1er janvier jusqu'au 31 décembre
Rendez vous demain à 11h, parce qu'on sera samedi demain *réfléchi*
et oui donc 11h
Tchao !